earlier this week the first clinical
trial of the vaccine candidate for the
virus began in Washington State as you
probably know the genetic sequence of
the virus was first published in January
but thanks to the unprecedented
partnership between the FDA NIH and the
private sector we've reached human
trials for the vaccine just eight weeks
later that's a record by many many
months it used to take years to do this
and and now we did it just in a very
short while that's the fastest
development in history of what we're
doing with regard to the vaccine making
very very big progress today I can
announce further steps to expand testing
capacity we're working with several
groups to determine if the self swab a
much easier process than the current
process that's not very nice to do I can
tell you because I did it but we have a
current process that's a little bit
difficult if you haven't done the the
groups are working on determining if a
self swab by an individual is as
effective as the other the others very
effective very accurate but we're gonna
see if we can do a self swab which is
would be a lot more popular I can tell
you that so and that would be
administered also by a health official
but it would be a lot easier to do the
the fact is that the health
professionals would it would free it
would free up a lot let me just say the
self swab is what it is it's a self
Swope you do it yourself the other has
to be issued by a health professional
and it's something that is quite
difficult and we think it's working out
for the self swab and if it would test
positive the people would go and they
would do what they have to do is but we
think that's probably working out I've
asked the FDA to cut through the red
tape and reduce regulatory barriers we
are looking at some very exciting things
and I'm going to be holding a second
news conference either today we're going
to talk about the FDA some things are
happening that are quite exciting and
we're gonna be doing that either later
today or tomorrow
fairly early tomorrow so we'll see what
happens but the FDA my instructions have
been working very very hard on a number
of developments and we'll be discussing
them with you later today or tomorrow
and this afternoon I'll be meeting with
nurses on the front lines of the battle
against the virus they're truly American
heroes they want to get it done they're
incredible people so we're going to be
meeting with nurses and actually look
forward to that very brave they're
taking a lot of risk and they they have
done it incredible job and they never
complain
you